CJ Stroud has been balling to start the
season so much that he claimed an
impressive stat that Patrick Mahones
owned for quite a bit stoud is currently
averaging 303 passing yards in his first
four games and that's the most in NFL
history more than Patrick Mahomes more
than any other great QB in NFL history
we know it's only through four games but
there's other context that makes the
stat even more impressive think about
how the current Houston Texans team is
built now they have a rookie head coach
in demo Ryan and a rookie offensive
coordinator in Bobby slowick not to
mention he's playing behind a banged up
offensive line that's missing three of
its five starters so yes we know it's
only been four games so far but he's
single-handedly outplaying some of the
League's best as a rookie quarterback
right now